the Sun in Australia has always been hot
it's not even ten o'clock in the morning
here and we are really sweating already
on average there's 300 days of sunshine
a year it's just roasting hot today okay
we get it
the Sun is strong so strong that it can
power this my name is dr. Gemma green
and I am a co-founder and the chairman
of power ledger and we're a technology
company that facilitates peer-to-peer
trading of electricity so every day
people that have got solar panels can
trade electricity with their neighbors
neighbors like Martin Martin is part of
a program that lets him and other
participants in the apartment complex
buy and sell excess power from each
other because I can buy and sell solar
power I can turn on the lights I can
turn on the ceiling fan I can turn on my
computer and charge it I can turn on the
kettle all on solar power or because we
can share the Sun we came up with this
concept recognizing that in the past 15
years households across Australia have
been installing solar panels but they
haven't had the ability to trade
electricity with each other so if one
house hasn't used its solar supply
residents can sell it to a house in need
they can even set their own price like
Martin does we can actually set what is
the minimum price we'd like to sell it
and there are other benefits sue it also
creates a sense of community because
people that have solar panels and
batteries can donate their electricity
to their community groups and schools I
guess it's just a small part of our
lifestyle going into the sharing economy
definitely no shortage of sunlight here
in Australia we've got enough Sun to run
this country's energy needs over and
over again my hopes for projects like
these is that they'll demonstrate what's
possible in our energy future and
citizens will be a power to get involved
and will really deliver a low-cost clean
and a resilient electricity systems
you
[Music]